the day comes when we find out president
biden's going to be our president okay
and it was official it was no longer
waiting the inauguration took place
president trump didn't show up
everybody's sitting there saying okay
this is our guy this is who we have to
run with this is who's representing the
free world today he's our
commander-in-chief
fast forward from that day to today is
today exactly what you expected it to be
is it better is it worse or is it
exactly what you thought it was going to
be well i didn't have a lot of the
expectations for
our current president
because
you know he basically
didn't show up during the primary
process and during the whole
presidential campaign
and when he did show up
it wasn't particularly impressive
but i knew that there were a lot of
other people who were
pulling the strings
and i have a reasonable idea of who
those people are
so i expected
a very leftward tilt
uh and that's exactly what has happened
when you say you have an idea of who
those people
reasonable idea about who those people
are
does the rest of america who votes also
know who those people are or is it
something that only some of the people
on the inside know who those people are
i think a lot of people who've been
paying attention to
the general tenor
of the country over the last
couple of decades
have a pretty good idea of who those
people are are you able to talk about it
or is it like this you know illuminati
secret type of freemason stuff that we
want to get at yale well let me just
say that there are people who have been
involved previously with trying to
fundamentally change your country
internally right
so it's okay so
you know what are you talking about
globalists some folks that are maybe i
think they're associated with some of
the globalists okay so why why would
they let's let's go there why would they
want to do that why would they want to
fundamentally change
uh the one country
that the world uses
the the five-letter word dream with you
know we don't use the dream word with
any country the only one we've ever used
it with was america the american dream
why are they trying to change it well
remember there have been people who have
uh disputed the legitimacy of our
governmental system since the very
beginning
they said you can't have a country
that's run on the will of the people
you have to have a monarch you have to
have a ruling body
and
those kinds of ideals have been around
from the very beginning and they're
still there
and there are those who believe that the
ruling class knows better than the
people
and uh
it's really for the good of the people
that you empower those people and that
they need to do whatever they
have to do in order to gain the power
in order to do quote good for the people
unquote yeah when you're saying the
monarch but aren't those guys from the
outside
so the argument is there's no way
america can make it without us we're a
monarch right they desperately need us
versus in this case you're saying last
20 years these are people on the inside
why are people on the inside
trying to break apart the one idea that
turned into whether this experiment that
turned into what it is today power
they want power they want control it's a
natural tendency
it's a human tendency
to want to control everybody to want to
control your environment
and that's why if you go back through
history and you look at various
societies
there is no period of time where people
can just live in peace where they can
just live and let live
no
no i got to control you i got to take
your stuff i got to be in
and in control of it we're all like that
we're like that but that is the very
reason that the founders of our country
work so hard on our constitution because
they knew there was a natural tendency
to want to control a natural tendency
for government to want to grow to
infiltrate and to control
and it was to give the people a tool
which would allow us to remain free it
is being challenged probably to the
severest degree right now so were they
also driven by power
the founders
uh they were different
tell me tell me in what way uh because
they actually people like george
washington
declined
to be made a monarch people wanted him
to be the monarch he said no
that's not the system that we have this
is about the people
and the freedom of the people and you
look at
you know john adams
and you know he said
our constitution was designed for a
moral
and religious people and is wholly
inadequate for the governance of any
other
you had you look at some of the writings
of people like thomas jefferson
who realized how important it was
for people to maintain freedom
and even though he had slaves
and several of the founders had several
didn't but several did
most of them
ended up freeing their slaves
and
i think
realizing the internal conflict
when you're saying that all men are
created equal
but then you have slaves
but
you know those who hate the united
states have tried to make slavery
a unique issue for us and they say we
are particularly evil because we had
slavery but if you know anything about
world history
you know that virtually every society
has to do with slavery
and that there are more slaves in the
world today than there have ever been at
any point in time when you look at human
trafficking
and the number one consumer of it the
united states of america
so do we still have some issues
absolutely there's no question about it
but we're not unique because because of
slavery we are unique only in the sense
that we had so many people who were
vehemently opposed to slavery that we
fought a bloody civil war to get rid of
it
and that's really what we need to teach
our children we need to teach them that
during slavery there were a lot of
people from all kinds of backgrounds
who
you know established the underground
railroad who did all kinds of things to
try to undermine
that concept of human bondage so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]